bien sûr pour l'europe c'est le réveil
il est brutal mais il y as réveil l'euro
peinait pour un autre monde un nom un
monde qui a cru comme benjamin constant
que
la fin lâche de la guerre était terminée
et que l'âge du commerce commencé et
nous nous réveillons brutalement de ce
monde où le tragique est de retour la
guerre est de retour le raf or le
rapport de force archaïque nous avons
affaibli notre souveraineté nous avons
affaibli nos capacités de puissance il
faudra restaurer la souveraineté
souveraineté alimentaire au moment où un
programme européen voudrait diminuer
notre production farm to fork il faudra
restaurer notre souveraineté énergétique
au moment où tentes avaient voulu nous
faire quitter justement l'énergie
nucléaire qui assure notre souveraineté
il faudra aussi rappelé aux juges
européens
avec la directive sur le temps de
travail appliqué à nos militaires que là
où il n'ya pas transfert de compétences
il ne saurait y avoir de primauté du
droit européen et puis restauré penser
pour nous seul et non pas avoir cette
sous traitance délégué aux américains de
sécurité penser notre sécurité la
puissance pour nous les européens avec
les britanniques sans doute avec ce
pilier de l'otan et puis aussi avec des
grands programmes d'armement je ne crois
pas à une armée aujourd'hui européenne
par contre il y attache main qu'il faut
qu'on entreprenne et enfin et pour
conclure ainsi recoller je pense que
faire le choix penser la puissance c'est
écarter de façon définitive
pour le moyen terme les perspectifs
fédéraliste elles ne peuvent
qu'affaiblir le seul instrument de
puissance que nous avons aujourd'hui en
europe qui sont les nations les nations
qui sont les dépositaires de la volonté
des peuples qu'est ce que nous montre
l'ukraine c'est que la guerre c'est un
choc des volontés et que depuis périclès
il n'y a pas de meilleure arme que la
volonté des peuples et que la volonté
des peuples au jour d'aujourd'hui au
moment où je vous parle réside dans les
nations qui peuvent coopérer mais c'est
si fondamental alors oui pour conclure
ce que je veux dire ici solennellement
ce soir dans cet hémicycle du sénat
c'est que le président de la république
a eu raison de qualifier cette guerre de
tournant historique
mais dans ce tournant historique il peut
y avoir un chemin français ce chemin
français ce sera le chemin de la liberté
le chemin de la souveraineté le chemin
de la nation parce que c'est l'histoire
de france parce que c'est la france dans
l'histoire et parce que c'est ce que
demandent à cor et à cri les armes à la
main aujourd'hui les ukrainiens le
peuple ukrainien un jour malraux que
vous connaissez que vous lisez monsieur
le premier ministre malo avait dit la
france n'est la france que lorsque elles
portent une part de l'espérance du monde
eh bien oui aujourd'hui la france porte
aussi une part de l'espérance du monde
ou plutôt une part de l'espérance
ukrainienne aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues nous sommes tous ukrainiens
alors oui vive la république vive la
france et surtout vive l'ukraine libre
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire que
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]